ich weiß wir haben gerade erst die
tomaten gepflanzt wir sind alle froh
dass der sommer vor der tür steht und
jetzt kommt da die marie daher und sagt
dann ist jetzt alle winter gemüse
anbauen wie kann es denn sein
gerade diejenigen von euch die
vielleicht noch nie im winter gegärtnert
haben finden dass wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen komisch aber jetzt ist
tatsächlich die zeit in der wir alle an
das wintergemüse denken müssen wenn wir
dann im winter immer noch aus unserem
eigenen garten ernten wollen was ich
wirklich sehr empfehlen weil so
wunderschön ist den garten das ganze
jahr über zu nutzen das ist auch für den
boden toll ihr müsst euch da keine
sorgen machen dass ihr den boden schadet
wenn ihnen noch mehr bepflanzt dass er
ihn irgendwie auslaugen würde das ist
nicht der fall
die ganzen bodenlebewesen und auch der
boden selber sind sehr sehr froh wenn
die das ganze jahr über bewachsen sind
so eine brachliegende wohnen ist sehr
schädlich für den boden das führt zu
erosionen die bodenlebewesen haben keine
nahrung und die pflanzen die auf dem
boden wachsen
die sind visum ab schutz für den boden
im winter zu gärtnern ist also nicht nur
toll für uns selber sondern auch für den
garten für das bodenleben und dafür den
boden zu schützen und aufzubauen
und deswegen werde ich euch gerne
herzlich einladen mit mir heute das
wintergemüse auszusehen ich mache das
auch heute und da zeige ich euch mal 30
gemüse die ihr im winter an bauen könnt
und von denen er fast alle jetzt
aussehen solltet also unesco
[Musik]
viele leute glauben immer gar nicht dass
man im winter wirklich so eine große
vielfalt an gemüse anbauen kann aber das
ist wirklich enorm man kann ganz vielen
gemüse viel mehr zutrauen als wir das
eigentlich so machen als es im garten
büchern oft steht denn viele gemüse sind
viel frost unempfindlicher als man so
denken mag deshalb werdet ihr euch
wahrscheinlich wundern über ein paar
kandidaten die ich jetzt hier aufführen
fangen wir gleich mit einem gemüse an
das vielleicht den einen oder anderen
verdacht ich erstaunt das ist der
kohlrabi da ist tatsächlich viel winter
härter als man dem oft zutraut und
zuschreibt und wir bauen kohlrabi super
gerne sogar im freiland an
natürlich wächst der auch im winter im
gewächshaus wunderbare geschützter desto
besser ist es natürlich aber wir bauen
ihn auch gerne im freiland an man kann
ihnen dann ja wenn es mal richtig kalt
werden sollte also wenn es mal eine
nacht mit minus 10 grad gibt oder
mehrere tage am stück sagen wir minus
sieben grad kalt ist dann kann man ihn
ja immer noch mit einem vlies abdecken
um ihn ein bisschen zu schützen
das macht den temperaturunterschied von
bis zu 5 grad außer dass also das ist
wirklich enorm und so kann man sehr sehr
gut auch im winter buch habe auch im
winter immer noch den eigenen
kollabieren und das ist wirklich super
toll gerade so an weihnachten der
familie zum essen aufzutischen mit ganz
vielen frischen garten genießen das
macht einfach stolz also müsst ihr
dieses jahr auf jeden fall ausprobieren
ja karotten bei euch auch immer im
winter an
sie lassen die einfach im bett stehen
die werden natürlich vorher schon reif
also die sind dann im winter wirklich
schon ausgereift deswegen muss man der
rechtzeitig daran denken die zu sehen
und dann denke ich die mit stroh ab und
dann kann man die nach bedarf einfach
nach und nach ernten und das ist gerade
bei karotten so toll weil die noch viel
süßer schmecken wenn man die im winter
erntet wenn die einmal frost bekommen
haben dann die einfach wie süßigkeiten
superlecker also es ist gar kein
vergleich zu dem sommer möhren da ich am
allerliebsten die sorte milan an und die
sorte gonsenheimer treibt das sind beide
sorten die sich auch super im beet
überwintern lassen dann ein kandidat den
jetzt schon super viele von euch anbauen
was ich richtig lustig finde
der salat baku ich kann euch den
sortennamen hier gerne nochmal
einblenden da war auch ein bisschen
herrscht ein bisschen verfügung wie man
den schreibe das ist ein ganz toller
winter salat der ziemlich france tat ist
den wir immer jedes jahr in ein beet
aussehen und da dann den ganzen winter
über pflücksalat von ernten das ist eine
super möglichkeit um auch ohne
gewächshaus wurde früh mit carsten den
ganzen winter über frischen salat aus
dem eigenen garten zu essen dann sähe
jetzt auch mein chicorée das ist eine
richtig coole angelegenheit bin theorie
kann man im winter im keller selber
treiben ich hab euch ja schon
versprochen dass ich euch das dann im
winter zeige
und da ist es jetzt an der zeit den
auszusehen hättet ihr auch schon ein
bisschen früher im jahr machen können
ich habe jetzt noch dass es auch nicht
schlimm so dass der bis zum herbst
richtig schöne wurzeln ausbilden kann
die crêpes man dann aus und schlägt die
ein so dass man sie im winter im keller
treiben kann eine super tolle sache
gerade um diese vielfalt im winter die
ja super schön ist noch ein bisschen
größer zu halten ich finde irgendwie
klar fehlen im winter die ganzen sommer
gemüse wie tomaten zucchini paprika
gerade wenn wir kaufen so was ja fast
nie im supermarkt so dass wir dann
einfach den ganzen winter darauf
verzichten
aber wenn man dann da für eine so große
palette von anderen gemüsen zur
verfügung hat dann ist das eigentlich
auch gar nicht schlimm und es gibt auch
diesen spargel effekt also wenn man
wirkliche saisonal ist dann freut man
sich eben nur auf jede neue ernte die
rein kommt also ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie ich diesen tomaten da
schon entgegenfiebert
und wie ich jeden tag schaue ob
vielleicht eine kleine grüne tomaten an
meinen pflanzen hängt weil das wirklich
ja ein richtiges fest ist ihr kennt das
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr euch jetzt nicht
komplett selbst versorgt aus dem eigenen
garten von spiel und von erdbeeren und
vielleicht auch von kirchen und das für
jedes gemüse zu haben ist schon ein
gemüse dass sich dieses jahr zum ersten
mal ausprobieren was auch winterhart ist
sind flowers browns das ist eine
kreuzung aus rosenkohl und grünkohl ich
bin sehr gespannt sie sind auch sehr
sehr hübsche pflanzen zumindest
auf den fotos sehen sie sehr schön aus
ich habe gerade welche gesellt und freue
mich schon die dieses jahr zum ersten
mal an zu bauen und werde dann auch im
winter berichten wie die sich so machen
zudem flowers boss muss ich noch sagen
dass das eine hybrid gemüse ist wir
bauen ja sonst nur samen feste gemüse an
und da gibt es eben keine samen festen
sorten dass er will ich euch noch mit
auf den weg geben also wenn euch das
super super wichtig ist dass kein f1
saatgut in euren garten kommt dann könnt
ihr keine flowers trotz anbau und
zumindest weiß ich nicht von
irgendwelchen samen festen sorten die es
da gibt werden dass doch so ist dann
belehrt mich gerne eines besseren unten
in den kommentaren finde ich auch super
wenn man da kein hybrid saatgut kaufen
müsste dann ein klassisches wintergemüse
der wirsing das machen wahrscheinlich
viele von euch auch wirsing ist absolut
frosthart das ist superschön den ganzen
winter über immer wieder vilsingen nach
bedarf aus dem garten ernten zu können
es ist natürlich immer wichtig das habe
ich jetzt schon mehrfach gesagt auf
diesem kanal dass man wenn die gemüse
eingefroren sind die finger davon lässt
und sie erst erntet wenn sie dann
aufgetaut sind weil die sonst zuhause
aufbauen und so matschig sind wie
tiefkühl spinat weil wenn man die
pflanze selber aufbauen lässt es in der
natürliche prozesse wo sie die
frostschäden benötigt bzw
die gar nicht erst entstehen weil die
pflanzen ja auch ihr eigenes
frostschutzmittel produzieren
tatsächlich abgefahren oder und dann
kann die pflanze wieder auftauchen ist
knackig aber wenn man die dabei
abschneidet und zuhause auftauen lässt
ein knapp klappt das nicht also immer
warten bis die pflanzen aufgetaut sind
ein weiteres standard geben wiese im
winter ist natürlich der auch gerade die
winter auch sorten es gibt sorten für
den sommer anbau und es gibt sorten für
den winter anbau da also darauf achten
dass man dann im winter die winter
sorten stehen lässt und die sag mal so
und woher auf ist das kriege ich auch
nicht mal so kann es kein hoch er ist
auch nicht so schlimm ich habe auch
schon sommer sorten überwintert aber man
merkt schon unterschied ob das jetzt nur
sommer- oder eine winter sorte ist ich
baue sehr gerne die sorte und blau
grüner winter an
das ist eine ganz tolle sollte zum
überwintern im biet bin kann man dann
auch einfach nach bedarf ehren
ganz tolle sache ist wenn man den nur
über der erde abschneidet und nicht bis
zur wurzel sticht und den ausgräbt weil
er dann nämlich wieder austreten kann
man hier noch mal bären ich habt ihr
schonmal topinambur angebaut das ist ja
dieses knollen gemüse dass man oft im
biomarkt bekommt völlig überteuert kann
sein dass es so teuer ist weil's so
ätzend ist die dinger zu putzen oder
aber das wächst auf jeden fall wie
unkraut dann wird es wirklich nicht mehr
los wenn man das einmal anbaut wir haben
das auch einmal gemacht in unserem
allerersten garten unter wachsen immer
noch zu wenig
ich weiß nicht ob die leute die da jetzt
wurde das so toll finden aber ja ich war
das nicht so lecker also ab und zu kann
man das schon mal essen aber es ist eben
ein erstaunliches gemüse dass man das
ganze jahr über ernten kann
da greift man dann einfach die knollen
aus die sind schon sehr gesund heißt es
und wenn sie euch schmecken dann ist das
eine super sache
um eben im winter immer noch so ein
wurzelgemüse zu haben was man ernten
kann sonst wenn das ja auch blattgemüse
jemand im winter ernten kann aber das
ist mal ein wort ihr gemüse schmeckt
sowieso eine mischung aus kohlrabi
kartoffeln
ich kann es gar nicht so gut beschrieben
vielleicht schafft dass jemand von euch
besser der weiß mit topinambur könnt ihr
gerne mal unten rein schreiben wenn das
jemanden interessiert schaut man nach ob
jemand beschrieben hat wie dubina mein
gemüse das wahrscheinlich wieder einige
erstaunen wird das auch ziemlich
winterhart ist es cool ich habe gerade
da hinten in meinem garten noch zwei
school pflanzen stehen die den ganzen
winter über ungeschützt im weg gestanden
haben
man kann die natürlich auch mit einem
vlies schützen wenn es allzu kalt wird
aber die haben das gut überstanden und
auch keine frostschäden davon getragen
so weit ich das jetzt beurteilt habe die
fragen jetzt langsam schon an zu blühen
also ich sollte die wirklich mal essen
aber wenn ihr weißkohl den ganzen winter
über ernten wollt dann macht es also
gerade im gewächshaus ist wirklich ein
jahr ziemlich risiko ein risikoreiches
unterfangen da sollte das gut klappen
und im freiland könnt ihr gerade wenn
ihr vielleicht in der raueren gegend
wohnt den ja immer noch ein bisschen ein
murmeln wenn es wirklich kalt wird und
dann immer das ganze jahr über euren
eigenen weißkohl ist und genau so
funktioniert das mit rotkohl wobei der
schauen ein bisschen mehr eine
frostbeule ist als der weiß cool so wie
ich das jetzt beobachtet habe also den
habe ich dann irgendwann im dezember
geerntet weil er doch arg frostschäden
bekommen hat und ich keine lust hatte
jetzt noch ein vlies tunnel aufzubauen
um ihn zu schützen aber rotkohl ist auch
viel frost unempfindlicher als man
meinen mag
und dann gibt es noch frühlingszwiebeln
dem man den ganzen winter über ernten
kann also eigentlich winter zwiebeln
oder die treiben dann aus und die kann
man den ganzen winter über einfach wie
frühlingszwiebeln kärnten die schneide
ich auch wie den lauch einfach über dem
boden ab ein paar zentimeter was ich
also noch stehen und dann treibt da
wieder eine neue zwiebel raus und man
kann die über den winter sicher dreimal
beenden weil die so schnell wieder
nachwachsen ein weiteres tolles
kohlgemüse ihr merkt schon cool ist sehr
frau staat deswegen haben viele gemüse
vor da müsst ihr mit eurer fruchtfolge
ein bisschen aufpassen dass ihr da nicht
so viele kohlgemüse rein bald aber das
ist der butter kohl auch ein sehr
spannender kohl der fast unbekannt ist
dann natürlich auch der grünkohl
grünkohl ist auch
völlig von start- früher hieß es ja
sogar der muss frost abbekommen bevor
man ihn essen kann dass es bei den neuen
sorten heutzutage nicht mehr so die kann
man auch essen ohne dass sie frost
abbekommen haben
aber sie schmecken besser wenn sie frost
abbekommen haben zumindest bilde ich mir
das ein ja ich weiß nicht wie viele von
euch schon mal postel ein angebaut haben
ein sehr nettes salat gemüse das absolut
frosthart ist bei postel 1 ist es sogar
so dass man die erst im herbst sehen
kann weil die brauchen eine temperatur
von unter 15 grad damit sie überhaupt
anfangen zu keimen
das heißt mit denen könnt ihr euch noch
ein bisschen zeit lassen
es gibt einige gemüse die sehr schnell
wachsen die man auch erst im herbst noch
sehen kann das ist gerade toll weil er
jetzt noch nicht alle gemüse abgeerntet
sind in den beeten so dass jetzt noch
nicht so viel platz ist für die ganzen
gemüse deswegen ziehe ich auch meine
ganzen kohle wechsel erst mal im
gewächshaus vor so dass die die beete
ich jetzt noch nicht blockieren wo er
jetzt noch das sommergemüse steht
sondern erst später ins bett wandern
können und die postel ein sind so ein
gemüse die man erst spät erhalten kann
wenn die allermeisten anderen gemüse
schon abgeerntet sind so dass dann auch
platz für das wintergemüse das ist immer
so ein bisschen so ein kunststück das so
zusammen zu puzzeln in der anbauplanung
dass man dann rechtzeitig genug platz
hat in den sommer beten um dann im
winter auch gemüse in den bieten stehen
zu haben
damit das rechtzeitige planung ist dann
auch erntereifes wenn es richtig kalt
wird genauso ist es mit dem feldsalat
auch den müsst ihr jetzt noch nicht
sehen dass wer jetzt noch zu früh
der wächst so schnell es ja auch nur ein
kleines gemüse der braucht nicht so viel
zeit bisher geführt und erwachsen ist
den kennt sie auch noch im september und
oktober sehen wenn vielleicht im garten
schon ein bisschen mehr platz ist und
feldsalat ist auch ein tolles gemüse was
die fruchtfolge angeht weil er in seiner
pflanzenfamilie die baldrian gewächse
das einzige gemüse ist dass wir so
normal in unserem garten anbauen und
dadurch habt ihr gar keine frucht
folgeprobleme den könnt ihr also quasi
in jedes beet serien das irgendwo frei
wird weil der auch kein problem damit
hat wenn im vorjahr da schon mal per
salat gesagt
nicht also ihr könnt wirklich jedes beet
ohne auf die fruchtfolge zu achten mit
feldsalat einsehen es ist kein problem
anderer toller salat der auch noch ein
bisschen zeit hat ist der asia salat da
gibt es ganz unterschiedliche sorten ich
mag gerne eine sollte die heißt green im
snow oder green es nun auf jeden fall
eine sehr witzige sorte dann gibt es
auch andere so hatten die vielleicht ein
bisschen milder sind damit kann man
wunderbar die winterlichen garten salate
aufpeppen finde ich echt ne coole sache
das wächst auch wie hunde also da muss
man wirklich nicht viel tun ist aber
auch eine folge wächst so dass das auch
wieder mit der fruchtfolge ein bisschen
eng werden kann also passt auf und jetzt
kommt noch ein gemüse an dass ihr jetzt
noch nicht denken müsste sich aber auch
schon mit auf den weg geben das wächst
auch super schnell dass ihnen die
radieschen
die müsst ihr auch erst im september
oktober selber um sie dann im winter
ernten zu können übrigens wenn ihr
gerade spät dran seid mit den aussaaten
oder noch platz im beet habt und ich
wüsste was ihr anbauen sollt dann
verlinke ich euch gerne da oben ein
video mit fünf gemüsen die super schnell
wachsen also mit denen ihr lücken füllen
könnt in ihren beeten und sehr schnell
eine erste ernte einfahren können das
sind die raketen gemüse liegt nicht nur
frühlingszwiebeln in eurem wintergarten
anbauen sondern auch frühlings knoblauch
die knoblauch pflanzen werden ja erst im
juli wirklich erntereif so dass man dann
die trockenen knollen ernten kann aber
bis in den frühling hinein kann man
wunderbar so frische knoblauch pflanzen
ernten ich kann euch mal gerade eine
frau hier wächst wenn ich den knoblauch
pendant und die könnt ihr einfach sowie
eine frühlingszwiebel klein schneiden
auch bis hier oben in die spitzen die
sind nicht so sehr wie sie aussehen und
die zum kochen verwenden im frühling und
im winter das ist eine super sache
gerade wenn so richtung april der lager
knoblauch langsam so ein bisschen ranzig
wird dann ist der frühlings knoblauch
schon so weit dass man den damit super
ersetzen kann
bärlauch wird dann auch reift das haben
sich die pflanzen schon ganz klug
ausgedacht dass sie niemals auf
knoblauch herum verzichten wirst
schwarzwurzeln kann man auch wunderbar
im winter anbau und da habe ich immer
hast kleine diskussion mit jackie
kennedy
meinen kursen mit dabei sind seine
mitarbeiterin und die steht total auf
schwarzwurzeln ich finde immer oder
zumindest in meinem kopf stelle ich es
mir so aufwendig vor schwarzwurzeln
anzubauen besonders schwarzwurzeln zu
ernten
ich weiß nicht ob das vielleicht nur
meine vorstellung ist ich habe auf jeden
fall noch nie schwarz wortsinn angebaut
habe ich keine lust habe
wenn ihr meint das ist total easy ist
die dann zu ernten und auszugraben
dann schreibt dass ich dann immer in die
kommentare dann lasse ich mich
vielleicht eines tages überzeugen aber
jackie steht total auf schwarzwurzeln
und sagt das ist eines der besten
wintergemüse überhaupt also musste ich
es mit in diese liste aufnehmen was ich
aber super cool finde auch ein
wurzelgemüse ist die pastinake dass die
namen schmecken ein bisschen wie möhren
aber sie sind aromatischer sie haben
mehr charakter sie sind fantastisch sie
sind ein bisschen sättigen da also es
geht mir einrichtungen kartoffel als in
richtung gemüse finde ich und
schwarzwurzeln kann man auch den ganzen
winter über problemlos im beet stehen
lassen und dann nach bedarf wir hatten
den ganzen wurzelgemüse muss man geben
ein bisschen drauf achten dass nicht
abreißt waren der boden gefroren ist und
war nicht das heißt wenn der
wetterbericht sagt dass es richtig kalt
wird dann lieber nochmal einmal in
freiluft supermarkt hinter dem haus
besuchen und für einen großeinkauf
machen so dass du die zeit wo der boden
gefroren ist wo die ganzen pflanzen
gefroren sind daneben gut überstehe ist
und genug gemüse im hausarzt um weiter
aus dem eigenen garten essen zu können
ein gemüse das richtig schnell wächst
das ja auch erst später im jahr sehen
könnt sind erbsen triebe tatsächlich
keine ärzte noch bei sehr niedrigen
temperaturen
die haben damit kein problem die kann
man ja auch im februar schon sein wenn
man normale erbsen anbauen möchte aber
ersten triebe sind super lecker super
süß und sehr also wirklich toll um damit
salate aufzufinden
die wachsen auch super schnell nach wenn
man die nur oben abschneidet und den
rest weiter wachsen lässt also probiert
das mal aus das ist echt ein richtig
tolles wintergemüse ihr werdet es mir
danken winter rettig ist ein gemüse das
erstaunlich rosstat ist ich finde immer
ja allzu viel muss man davon nicht
machen es ist nicht unbedingt das
leckerste gemüse da gibt es andere
kandidaten die besser schmecken aber
wenn du auf rettig stehst dann bau auf
jeden fall rettig an im winter weil da
musst du nicht tun du musst du auch
nicht schützen
der wächst wunderbar den ganzen winter
hindurch sodass du ihnen immer nach
bedarf ihren kampf tätig ist übrigens
auch sehr gut gegen husten ein anderes
tolles wintergemüse ist der spinat ich
kann mir ein winter ohne spiel hat das
an ihr schon gar nicht mehr vorstellen
das gehört irgendwie dazu werden dass
quasi alle zwei wochen so eine richtig
fette spinat lasagne und wir machen ein
liter sahne in einem vorraum spieler
ich weiß schon warum wieso lag aber ich
bin hart ist einfach ein tolles gemüse
auch spinat kuchen kann man daraus
machen wir machen so eine art
ich weiß gar nicht wie das heißt free
tartar oder so so eine pfanne wo man den
spinat so buck das ist super lecker kann
man so viel draus machen also wenn du
auf spinat stehst einbau auf jeden fall
welchen in deinem garten an
es gibt ja so hatten die er für den
sommer anbau gedacht sind wie zum
beispiel die sorte gamma sein also wenn
ihr jetzt noch sommer spinat aussehen
könnt wäre es gerade noch rechtzeitig um
das zu machen ansonsten für den winter
war ich immer die sorte winter riesen
mangold kennt ihr genauso anbauen wie
spinat er ist auch sehr sehr frostig bei
am liebsten diesen bunten mangold an der
in orange pink weiß gelb und rot
daherkommt weil es einfach super schön
aussieht die sorte oder der sorten mix
heißt rainbow und ein gemüse was ihr
auch anbauen können auch im winter
escola gerade die wilden arten von
okular also nicht der kultur rucola
sondern ein wilder rucola ist auch sehr
frost hat der sieht sich also wieso
immer selber außen vermehrt sich im
garten weiter zumindest wenn man ihnen
blühen und absahnen lässt dass es kein
problem dann einfach in einer ecke im
garten immer rucola zur verfügung zu
haben
auch im winter den rucola ist sehr
frosthart und ich habe noch nie erlebt
dass uns kukula irgendwie erfroren wäre
da kann man wirklich einfach hingehen
egal wann und sich dunkler flecken auf
die pizza backen mit denen salat machen
zusammen mit parmesan es ist auch ein
sehr frost das wintergemüse mit ein
gemüse dass ich super spannend finde für
den winter ist der zirkel der macht
richtig was ihr in eurem bieten
der kohl ist darauf gezüchtet dass er
möglichst hübsch aussieht das heißt
nicht dass man ihn nicht essen kann der
ist essbar
sie wird aber nicht als lebensmittel
verkauft sondern als blume und den wir
da freue ich mich schon wahnsinnig drauf
ich habe den gerade gesät und ich habe
ja ganz unterschiedliche sorten gekauft
und da gibt es wirklich müsst ihr mal
googeln das sind so schöne
unterschiedliche kohle liman da anbauen
kann die man gleichzeitig auch essen
kann und die dann so richtig schöne
farbtupfer im wintergarten hergeben
stellt euch mal vorgelegt und dann habt
ihr seid eure ziel kohlpflanzen stehen
und ja es ist wirklich eine ganz tolle
sache von der hierzulande noch kaum
jemand weiß also ich kenne niemanden der
zieht aus jackie da werde ich euch im
winter dann auch zeigen wie der aussieht
da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche sorten
also macht euch da mal schlau
ich würde mich richtig freuen wenn ihr
zum beispiel auch in der bekämpfung
gruppe dabei seid wenn ihr dann im
winter mal fotos gepostet weil ja es
gibt kaum ein gemüse das so so so schön
ist wie türkei so schnappt euch eure
saatgut tütchen macht dieses wochenende
mit und wer jetzt zu sagen mit mir eure
wintergemüse ich freue mich auf jeden
fall von euch zu hören unten in den
kommentaren verraten mir mal welche
wintergemüse ihr schon an gebaut habt
und ob er vielleicht inspiration
bekommen habt dieses jahr noch ein paar
mehr auszuprobieren das war jetzt
wirklich nur so ein best-of sagen wir
mal es gibt noch viel mehr gemüse die
man im winter anbauen kann also lass uns
da gerne ein bisschen plaudern ich freue
mich immer von euch zu hören wenn ihr
noch ideen habt worüber es videos machen
kann dann schreib mir das auch unten in
die kommentare
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat und
wenn euch das weitergeholfen hat dann
gebt dem video gerne einen daumen nach
oben das hilft mir und meinem kanal
wirklich ungemein schön ich kann euch
gerne mal hier drüben eine gartentour
verlinken die ich diesen winter gemacht
habe dann könnt ihr mal sehen was sich
da alles geerntet habe und da seht ihr
mal das
der garten den winter über wirklich voll
bewachsen ist da gibt es kaum ein leeres
plätzchen also schaut da trieben gerne
mal vorbei und da unten verlinkt ich
euch auch noch ein video das euch
interessieren könnte ansonsten sehen wir
uns nächsten samstag wieder bis dahin
tschüss